[Music]
why I like to save the goats so that's a
question I have often been asking myself
because I can't answer it this is
somehow my mission to take care of the
goats somebody had to do it and i falled
in love with them
[Music]
my name is Johanna Burt Massaro stuffed
it and I'm a goat farmer in Iceland for
the last 16 years I have been trying to
build up and protect or goat bleats they
have been isolated in Iceland for 1,100
years they came by the Vikings from
Norway and from Scotland Ireland though
I haven't gota twice been less than 100
animals in 1962 there was just about 60
70 goats left they have been a very big
tension of both in breeding and
disappearing I got them here and since
then it helped in my passion to breed up
this type of the gods this is the only
farm we are trying to live from the
coats to milk them and make products if
you are trying to save a breed you have
to use what they give we have been doing
a lot of different things to raise
attention for the goats and Game of
Thrones for shooting here 20 of the
goats were used
they would not be here anymore if I
wouldn't have taken care of them I'm
very proud to look at my floss and see
that they are life because of my work
it's just like when you have children
you are proud of them I'm very proud of
my goats
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
catching the fish is definitely the
biggest element
favorite part is always to take you know
when the fish takes apply adrenaline
just goes off
just testing when your own business than
all of that's a lot of fun
[Music]
we are at Tunga field which is a seat
rodriram on the south coast of iceland
this river is known for very big fish I
think it's because of all the glaciers
and is fairly new geologically always
this part of country
it's fun being fishing in this toilet
once you have your first fish it starts
to be a lot more about the nature the
river the company
and being outside getting away from your
normal life
really
doing something else for two or three
days or a week
[Music]
that's what it's all about
[Music]
and fly-fishing offers a never ending
journey for speak although it sounds too
cliche
you're never gonna master no matter how
hard you try no matter how much time you
spend doing it you're never ever gonna
mask
[Music]
siggi Ron Hill Marcin is an Icelandic
Baker with an unconventional oven he
bakes bread by burying it underground
where it's heated for 24 hours by nearby
hot springs it's very common to see hot
springs here in Iceland there is
constant lava crawling under us this
lava is heating up water and this water
comes boiling up on the surface we could
put it in the oven but this is much more
fun Iceland is one of the most volcanic
regions in the world with 30 active
volcanoes at any one time that helps
create an abundance of hot springs some
with boiling hot water and siggy uses
them to his advantage he specializes in
baking who've abroad a traditional
Icelandic rye bread recipe that dates
back hundreds of years I know for sure
that in this minutes I can track it down
as far as late 1800 something my
grandmother taught my mother how to bake
this bread and my mother taught me in
the hospital right bread recipe we have
rye flour sugar baking powder soft and
milk we put this in a pot we put butter
in the pot then we wrap it with plastic
foil and we put it down in our hot
spring hole for 24 hours it's very
obvious to see if the ground is hot or
not I never use a thermometer if I need
to check the heat I just use this one
our biggest challenge is rain
if it rains a lot these holes that we
are using can cool down and if they are
not hot enough obviously the bread
doesn't bake completely everybody eats
our bread our visitors the locals
offspring rye bread has a unique place
that you don't get from ovens the
texture of this bread is quite special
it's quite heavy it's not the typical
light bread when you show this to
travelers that come to Iceland and you
see their faces they go WOW then you
start to think that this is quite
amazing as you know is the land of Fire
and Ice Iceland is an island of extremes
where people wage a relentless war
against the elements
it's seriously unpredictable weather
it's basically like a battle zone of
different high pressure low pressure
areas anything it happened
dangerous conditions mean people can
find themselves in serious trouble
and in need of rescue but there's a
problem the small country has no army or
government program to help so citizens
form the Icelandic search-and-rescue
team known as Isis or a national
emergency force they're everyday people
willing to risk their lives to save
others in the worst conditions
imaginable you're going out and the
conditions when everyone else is
supposed to be inside so you have to be
a little bit crazy but in a good way
ice is the community of volunteers that
responds to calls for help all year
round in Iceland I think to take part in
ice or you just have to be willing to
put forward the skills that you have
I sometimes consider a rescue team like
a village you need every kind of person
to make everything work I think it's
kind of amazing because it's all
relative we have professors taxi drivers
carpenters plumbers office workers just
name it
men and women all kind of people
it's very hard to imagine Iceland
without our association and all teams
[Music]
Iceland's breathtaking landscape
attracts tourists and adventure seekers
from all over the world but that beauty
can lure people to a false sense of
security the weather conditions can
change faster than anything else you can
have a sunny day and in two minutes its
storm wind rain even snow infest all the
time people are just going for a hike
and they're pretty confident that the
mountain that they're going on is not
dangerous you have the lower glaciers
which have become quite a popular
tourist attraction and people are going
for walks on these and they are full of
crevasses extremely dangerous super
slippery and then they fall over and
hurt themselves then they have to rely
on search and rescue to come and find
them for average citizens to gain the
skills needed to be part of ice are they
go through a rigorous 18-month training
program they learn mountaineering
climbing and orienteering it takes a
huge skill set but when you can't deal
with any weather then you can go out and
help people
[Music]
across the whole country I think our
team's get to four point five colors per
day there were people running from their
own work or family to join the team when
I get called out we have three coats its
f1 high priority life at stake
f2 not as high priority and f3 easygoing
when you get called out high priority
and you get your text that it says a
child the new heart goes pounding almost
out of the chest to run out I don't even
say goodbye to my children or white I
can remember one called
boy that lost interest all I could think
about was my son if he got lost I would
like to have everyone help so
a lot of emotions comes up when you get
caught up I'm proud of the unity and the
fact that people are willing to
sacrifice their spare time to help
others the feeling that I get when we
rescue someone it doesn't have to be me
that finds the person can be another
group searching somewhere else but we're
searching for the same person when
someone gets found you get this wellness
feeling we did something right there
our heroes in in so many ways but in
icelandic culture we don't do a lot of
hero talk no I'm not a hero I'm just a
part of a team I'm not a hero no I'm
just a normal person I'm very proud of
the Association and what they have
accomplished they've saved a lot of
lives
[Music]
Adventure photographer Chris Burkard is
an expert in photographing surfers
riding the coldest most punishing waves
on the planet he's accustomed to
battling the elements in his work but
one storm in Iceland nearly broke him
it was like Armageddon we had basically
just been you know totally beaten to
shreds I mean it was told darkness the
storm cancelled BER cards expedition but
the decision to stay in Iceland resulted
in a once-in-a-lifetime photographic
opportunity that he never expected this
is it this is it right here
he managed to capture an epic adventure
under the greatest light show on earth
if you look at the Northern Lights and
you don't question your place in the
world then there's there's something
dead inside yet
[Music]
I grew up kind of frolicking along the
coast here in central California I would
drive up the coast and try to surf with
my friends and these remote little
beaches and stuff and to be honest like
that really set the president for me
that like I wanted to just go explore I
first picked up a camera right around
the age of I think 1819 I realized this
was it this was like a perfect medium
for expression like this was as good as
it could get when I grew up I didn't
have a passport never traveled
internationally and as I realized that
photography could be this tool to see
the world I was like oh my gosh like
this this is it this could be my ticket
after years of photographing and
stunning beach towns around the world
Burkhart decided to shift his focus to
colder climates I had the dream job and
then I realized that I want to document
places that it might not be around
forever and I want to share the
experience of of the importance of
seeing these places because I want
people to know that these places are out
there there's been a lot of zero Degree
days a lot of days where you're standing
on the beach or shooting somewhere on a
mountainside and you're just your organs
are hurting because it's so cold and
you're touching metal equipment and your
hands are just getting brittle and
cracked it's type 2 fun you know you
look back and you chuckle but in the
moment it's pretty brutal you want to be
somewhere else my work is taking me to
some of the harshest environments on the
planet I seek out some of the last
places on earth where you can really
find these raw environments
of all the places he's been one trip to
Iceland pushed him closest to his
breaking point what started off as a
trip to photograph epic waves became an
epic battle with the elements this last
winter during the darkest and coldest
time of year we set out to Iceland I
didn't really have any idea of how it
would go
there was this one location in this
remote national park that I wanted to go
access all I knew is that there was a
boat captain that was willing to take us
there
we finally made that remote beta's
national park we're sitting there in the
boat and we're looking at this risk
waived it was everything we had hoped
for the captain came out and said that
the largest storm in 25 years was coming
right now and we literally had to turn
and hightail out of there back to the
harbor
the weather change like that and it was
like Armageddon people were just like
getting food storage and stocking up all
the flights are grounded so we made this
decision that we were gonna drive 11
hours the next safe town so we don't
come home empty-handed we were all just
defeated but still new that was like
something else out there for us and we
just knew that we wanted to play it out
that was probably not the smartest call
and we weren't what we originally
planned
we were like forced to stay a little bit
longer and after that storm subsided we
realized that with that storm brought
incredible surf and not only that but a
Northern Lights round if the weather
could just hold off for that much longer
this would be something that would be in
history books
I convinced one of the guys to go out
the hardest thing was just keeping my
focus what I was seeing you know is
these amazing patterns of blue and
orange and red and green you know
trickling the sky this is maybe one of
the most insane things I've ever seen in
my life so every so often I'd get lost
just staring at the sky somebody would
holler and I would look and see them to
be have a cave okay here it is
there we go been someone's going
shivering you're sitting there you're
kind of like basically going through all
the emotions but for me anything worth
pursuing is gonna require you to suffer
a little bit through all that we came
away with this experience that was
actually far better than anything we
could have ever planned for it changed
everything I thought about what was
possible
I am nothing more than to simply just
document the beauty of the world if a
photograph that somebody sees is
powerful enough to make them go
somewhere they've never been the outside
of their comfort zone spend their time
that's what I speak to is like how we
can do that more
I guess we want to just inspire future
generations to be willing to thrust
themselves into situations like not
being willing to go and everything else
says not to even when all the odds are
stacked against you you can still create
something beautiful it's very different
from every other collection in the world
and if you're a collector at heart you
can't really stop my name is Jeff -
Siham I'm the curator and owner of the
Icelandic phallological Museum
my father was giving a ride pool penis
epistle back in 1974 as a joke then
that's almost part the idea you know to
start collecting these things all the
lights are made from scrotum skins right
now we have 285 different specimens it's
still growing the collection we get
maybe three to five every year the most
fascinating things is the diversity
there are huge differences in size
shapes a color etc here is the the
biggest specimens we have it's a sperm
whale it's about 70 kilos maybe 150
pounds and here is one of my favorites
the world was one the hardest to get was
the human one no question about that it
was 95 when he died so this person is a
bit shrunken you know
it's what it does to be for your
everything shrinks but we're hopeful
we'll get a better example soon people
say you know they are just happy because
they realize that there's nothing loot
here there's no pornography it's just
you know education and fun
[Music]
you